want to let everybody know that this
morning I file to be the Republican
nominee for president of the United
States this is a a decision that my wife
and I decided to do because we live in
complicated times and we need Common
Sense there are a number of generational
defining challenges that we're faced
with in the United States of America
everything from the Chinese government
trying to surpass us as the global
superpower the fact that inflation is
persistent at a time when Technologies
like artificial intelligence is going to
upend every single industry and our kids
or their their scores and math science
and reading are the lowest they've ever
been in this Century these are the
issues we should be talking about and to
be frank I'm pissed that we're not
talking about these things I'm pissed
that our elected officials are telling
us to to hate our neighbors right our
neighbors are not our enemies they're
our fellow Americans who we just happen
to have a disagreement with